[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome
to the quick start
for Cloud Storage,
Google Cloud's object
store for unstructured data
such as images, videos,
and documents.
In this video,
we're going to walk
through how to perform basic
tasks in Cloud Storage using
the gsutil command line tool.
To start, visit
console.cloud.google.com
to open the Google
Cloud Console.
This web portal lets
you manage and explore
your cloud resources
directly from a browser.
To get started
with Cloud Storage,
you need a Google Cloud project.
You can use an existing
project or set up a new one.
Next, activate Cloud
Shell by clicking its icon
to the right of the search bar.
Cloud Shell is an online
development environment
that comes preloaded
with helpful tools
for interacting with
your cloud resources.
Once it launches, click
the Maximize button
to increase the size of
the Cloud Shell terminal.
Now you'll run some commands
using the gsutil command line
tool, which allows you to
interact with your Cloud
Storage resources
from command line.
gsutil stands for
Google Storage Utility.
Now create a Cloud
Storage bucket.
Buckets are the basic
containers that hold your data
in Cloud Storage.
To create a bucket, run
the gsutil mb command
and provide a global unique
name for your bucket.
This demo uses a bucket
named storage-quickstart-777.
But you must choose
your own bucket name.
Next, I'll put an
object into your bucket.
First, run the wget command
to download a kitten.png image
to the Cloud Shell environment.
Then run the gsutil cp
command to copy the image
from your local Cloud Shell
environment to your Cloud
Storage bucket.
Congratulations,
you've successfully
outputted an object
to your bucket.
Now download the object
from Cloud Storage
back to your local
Cloud Shell environment
using the gsutil
cp command again.
You'll download the object
as a file called kitten2.png.
If you run ls, you can see that
it was downloaded successfully.
Within Cloud
Storage buckets, you
can create folders to
organize your objects.
With gsutil cp, you
can upload an object
to a specific folder in
a Cloud Storage bucket.
This command creates a
folder called folder1
within your bucket and uploads
the kitten image there.
You can also list the contents
of a bucket or folder using
the gsutil ls command.
Here, you can list the
contents at the top level
of your bucket.
The two items listed are
kitten.png and folder1.
You can also list details for
an individual object using
gsutil ls with the -l flag.
Here, you can list details about
kitten.png, such as its size
and date of creation.
Now let's explore how to manage
Cloud Storage permissions.
Run the gsutil iam
ch command, which
allows you to change permissions
for a given Cloud Storage
bucket.
Here, you specify that you want
to give all users permission
to view objects
stored in the bucket.
The command is successful
if no error is returned.
To remove public view
access to these objects,
run the gsutil iam ch
command with the -d flag.
You may also want to
give a specific person
access to your bucket.
This command gives the
gcpstudentdevelopers7@gmail.com
account permission to read and
write object to your bucket.
To remove this permission, run
the same gsutil iam ch command,
but with the -d flag.
To delete an object, run
this gsutil rm command
to delete kitten.png from
the Cloud Storage bucket.
And finally, run this command
to delete the Cloud Storage
bucket.
The -r flag is added so that
everything inside of the bucket
is deleted as well.
And that's it.
You're now equipped
to perform basic tasks
in Cloud Storage using the
gsutil command line tool.
While this video
used Cloud Shell,
you can also use gsutil
from your local computer.
Check out the gsutil Getting
Started Guide, linked
in the description below, to
learn how to install gsutil
on your local computer.
Make sure to check out the
rest of our Cloud Storage
documentation at
cloud.google.com/storage/docs,
so you can learn more about how
to store and manage your data
in Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]